الانتقال الى تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا تشتد وتيره المعارك على محاور
القتال في اقليم دومباس الشرقيه اوكرانيا
قياده
الاركان وثمانين هجوما روسيا معظمها على
محاور القتال في الاقليم خلال الساعات
الاخيره واضافت القياده ان القوات الروسيه
لا تتوقف عن محاولات اختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه في محيط باخموت
قرار استراتيجي وليس سياسيا يتخذه
العسكريون الذين لا توجههم الدوافع
السياسيه
هذا وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
المعارك في خطوط الجبهه بانها تزداد شراسه
نتعامل مع الوضع في كل خطوط الجبهه
بالتفصيل والمحور الاصعب هو باخموت
والمعارك الدائره للدفاع عن المدينه وقد
افاد جنرال انه منذ اخر اجتماع قتل نحو
800 من الاعداء على الاقل روسيا لا تبالي
بارواح المقاتلين على الاطلاق وتدفع بهم
دفعا الى الهجوم على مواقعنا ان حده
القتال اخذه في الازدياد